one way of detecting a facial expression
automatically is by using what we call
geometric features so these are features
that look at the shape of a face for
instance a p-- of your mouth
the distance between let's say your
eyelids obviously when I blink the
distance between my two eyelids will go
lower lower lower lower until it's zero
and then after while it goes up enough
and open again it's a very
straightforward direct relation between
the feature the distance between two
facial points and the expression when
I'm blinking or not however finding
those facial points in the first place
is not so simple you have to again turn
these pixels in an image in two
locations with these facial points
traditionally what people did is they
build little facial point detectors so
there were really models that could tell
for a given little image patch of let's
say 16 by 16 pixels whether that was the
location of the eye and then what you
would do is you would scan through every
possible region in the face until you
found the location that set the highest
confidence I am the eye it's called
binary classification or at least it's
it's optimizing a single value until
you've got the highest value and that's
where you want to be that is problematic
in multiple ways it's it's a problem
because you have to search everywhere
it's also a problem because you can't
get stuck in what's called local optima
where you think you're at a maximum but
actually it's not because if you have a
local Optima let's say you want to
maximize the probability of this area
being a face and we're scanning through
all the different possible pixel
locations and as our probability goes up
because we're near to what we think is
an eye then it goes down now normally
we'd be doing something which is called
gradient descent so we'd be following
steps in that direction until we get a
flatline so the gradient is zero there
and we're saying we're done we found the
point this is the location over facial
point however we've stopped here maybe
this was not a real Optima but that's
later and even bigger we've missed out
because we stopped searching so that's a
local optimum and that's a big problem
when you do search searches for facial
points like this in a classical binary
classification search the alternative
solution is search everything but that's
generally too costly to do x resources
yeah what we did is we turned this idea
around so instead of asking every
location in the face are you di we're
going to ask a location hey where is the
eye so it's going to tell us well you
have to go 15 pixels in that direction
in the in the X Direction the horizontal
direction you have to forego 5 pixels
down in the vertical direction and you
can do this because there's something
called regression which is again a
machine learning technique and whereas
binary classification only tells you yes
or no regression actually gives a real
real-valued output so you could use it
to predict temperature or in this case
displacements in terms of the number of
pixels in one direction or the other so
we get a little vector that points from
the patch where we asked so let's say
I'm looking for my inner eye corner you
get a little pixel here around my
eyebrow because there's a relation
between of course the appearance of an
eyebrow and where my eyes are because my
eyes are always below my eyebrows it can
tell me meanwhile you have to go in that
direction yes so to build such models
you need quite a lot of data so we
generally tend to use a thousand two
thousand three thousand faces where I
painstakingly and my colleagues have
painstakingly located 68 different
facial points on on that face and we
and from that data exactly what the
relation is between the appearance of
the eyebrow and where my eye corner is
and we do that for every possible
variations so we have 68 facial points
that we want to know where they are but
actually to Train we're going to use
millions of locations in the entire face
to give the relation between every
possible area where we might possibly
test and where the facial point is
exactly so every part of the face can
sort of vote for where the facial point
let's say the eye corner is and then we
combine all those votes and you can
imagine that the votes coming from a bit
further away we'll have more error will
be less confident but as we are voting
in one general direction you get closer
and closer to the real point also when
you make errors errors tend to be random
they seem to go in all direction so they
cancel each other out
whereas all the correct predictions will
tend to predict in the same direction
they all go towards my eye corner so
they add up and all the errors cancel
out because they're in random directions
that's a really nice way of doing it
and we keep repeating that until we
until the confidence is high enough or
whether we've reached some maximum
number of iterations and we apply a
little shape model on this so we're not
but we're using a particular shape model
which looks at whether the constellation
of points that said constellations of my
mouth whether they are feasible whether
they are possible we're not going to
look for the maximum likelihood for the
most probable consolation because the
most probable constellation of my mouth
is a neutral face that will mean that
when I'm smiling it would say well yes
that's possible but it's less probable
because normally you have your mouth
shut okay not for me my mouth is usually
open but in general it's
it would tend to watch a neutral face so
we're not going to look for the most
probable shape but we're just going to
look for whether a shape is feasible now
my upper mouth and my upper lip mouth
point will not be below my lower lip
that's not really possible that's your
eye points will not be below the mouth
points so those kind of constraints will
see what is possible what's not possible
and if it's impossible we replace it by
something that we think is the best
location but that's certain let's say
that's an error detection filter that we
apply afterwards now once you have these
facial points you can now start doing
some reasoning let's say we want to look
at the facial points of the mouth and
see what if somebody's smiling so if you
have a neutral face you would have mouth
points perhaps like this we have the two
mouth corners and two points on the
upper lip and two points on the lower
lip now you get sort of a mouth like
this
that would be your neutral face now when
somebody smiles these mouth corners will
go up and out and that will results in a
little bit accentuated perhaps your
mouth corners go up that's quite a joker
smile but as you can see you can just
look at let's say the angle here and
compare that with the angle here of a
two and you will see that alpha 2 is
much smaller than alpha 1 and therefore
you can use that somebody smiling in
general we don't actually learn a set of
rules like this but these become
features in our machine learning
techniques again we usually use support
vector machines neural networks deep
learning whatever is most suitable for
the types of data that we have and
that's how we detect smiles from
geometric features matter if people are
completely different in ethnic terms or
in local insects or yes there will be
differences between gender
or ethnicity in sort of the the global
shape but the changes in shape the fact
that these mouth points go out and up
and the angles go down they are the same
for everybody for everybody because
everybody has the same underlying
structure of facial muscles and we all
smile in the same way
I'll show you the big machine that's sir
so this is a hundred thousand processors
pretty good machine